le face à face entre les gares de
mobiliser le personnel pénitentiaire est
tendue mais il n'est pas hostile
aucun incident ne viendra faire déraper
la confrontation l'entrée de la prison
est bloqué depuis ce matin 6h et les
surveillants de nuit n'ont pas encore
été relevées dedans comme dehors le
personnel solidaires du mouvement
national veut voir circuler ces images
celle d'une martinique déterminé à
porter haut ses revendications
c'est extraordinaire ce qui se passe là
aujourd'hui à l'intérieur de cette
prison c'est même historique
je félicite jamais sur la plus haute
marche de l'estiment les personnels
aujourd'hui la solidarité la somme des
corps administratifs personnels
initiation technique tout le monde
le service de nuit c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui madame belloubet monsieur
macron et et monsieur philippe prenne
conscience que même en outre-mer on est
capable de hausser le niveau
comme plusieurs fois la semaine dernière
les gendarmes viennent extraire des
détenus une comparution immédiate et ne
faut dition devant les juges et les
moyens sont là pour ne pas compromettre
ses opérations s'agit d'une opération
effectivement assimilable à une
opération de maintien d'ordre
en tout cas le but est de permettre
l'exercice du service public de la
justice c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que
les détenus soient présentés devant les
magistrats tels que
le calendrier le prévoyait beaucoup
d'hommes donc pour faire sortir ces dix
détenues et bien c'est un effectif qui
est en proportion
celui du nombre de manifestants à la
fois donc leur détermination leur volume
la relève de l'équipe de nuit ne se fera
qu'après le transfert des détenus mais
l'ensemble du personnel est satisfait
d'avoir fait corps devant la force
publique
nous réclamons des moyens nous est
clairement dit et qu'on prenne en compte
notre sentiment d'insécurité
voilà mais je ne vous cache pas que ce
qu'on vit au quotidien nous à
l'intérieur de la prison les gendarmes
le vivent sur la voie publique
d'autant que les policiers donc de toute
façon quoi qu'on en dise que l'on soit
pénitentiaire que l'on soit policier de
long soit gendarmes c'est le même combat
il saigne le savent pour les détenus
sans doute très perturbé par le
mouvement pas de promenades aujourd'hui
le lundi n'est pas jour de parloir ce
qui limite les frustrations dans
l'établissement